[Música]
con nuestra primera invitada del día nos
vamos hoy hasta chile porque el martes
el congreso del país apoyo con amplia
mayoría la propuesta de ley para que la
jornada laboral se reduzca desde las 45
a las 40 horas semanales de forma
gradual en 5 años y sin reducción de
sueldos una victoria para Gabriel borich
y un paso hacia adelante en derechos
laborales que deja chile como el único
país de la región junto a Ecuador y
Venezuela con este tipo de jornada según
la organización para la cooperación y el
desarrollo económico América Latina es
una de las regiones con más horas de
trabajo anuales para ahondar en la
medida hablamos con Carol cariola
coautora del proyecto y diputada por el
partido comunista chileno Carlos cariola
Muchas gracias por atendernos hoy en
France 24 quería preguntarle porque esta
era una iniciativa que el partido
comunista puso sobre la mesa hace Ya
seis años Ya la que solo la extrema
derecha del país se ha opuesto que había
imp entonces que hasta ahora chile no
hubiera aprobado una medida como ésta
Buenos días Rodrigo Bueno muy contenta
de poder conversar con ustedes saludar a
Colombia y Bueno a todos y todas quienes
nos están viendo para nosotros esta es
una medida muy importante una medida
histórica en la que hemos venido
trabajando durante mucho tiempo ya Son
seis años desde que presentamos este
proyecto de ley y que bueno el
presidente Gabriel boric tal como lo lo
mencionabas tú ha decidido respaldar por
lo tanto eso nos permitió que el
proyecto de ley pudiera avanzar a ley de
la República ya el día de ayer antes de
ayer Perdón ya han pasado días el
proyecto fue aprobado fue eh despachado
a ley por lo tanto estamos ya en su
etapa final solamente queda la
promulgación por parte del presidente
había mucha oposición en un momento por
parte de El gran empresariado también
había disposición del gobierno anterior
el presidente Sebastián Piñera estaba en
contra esta propuesta así lo manifestó
él y también gran parte de sus ministros
por eso es que Durante los años
anteriores no pudimos avanzar al
contrario lo trababan con
descalificaciones con mentiras con
distintas cosas que lamentablemente nos
hicieron mucho daño en el debate pero
que en este último periodo lo logramos
subsanar con diálogo con conversación se
estableció un diálogo tripartito entre
el empresariado las pymes las pequeñas
medianas y microempresas los
trabajadores y trabajadoras Y por
supuesto también el poder político tanto
El Ejecutivo como los parlamentarios y
parlamentarias para llegar a un buen
acuerdo que nos permita tener hoy el
proyecto de ley ya materializado en ley
de la república
quería preguntarle por ciertas críticas
de algunos sectores de izquierdas no
parlamentarios que critican precisamente
el margen de cinco años que se da para
llegar a las 40 horas semanales se debe
quizás este margen a esos diálogos de
los que usted nos hablaba para poder
llegar a un consenso amplio
bueno primero esto generó mucha
discusión Rodrigo como te comentaba
anteriormente porque habían algunas
visiones catastrofistas que decían que
si se implementaban las cuarenta horas
de un día para otro la economía si va a
venir abajo que las pymes evidentemente
si van a ver afectadas y en cierta
medida al menos respecto de las pequeñas
y medianas empresas la realidad sí era
compleja al solicitar una implementación
inmediata por eso es que parte de los
diálogos llegaron a la a la idea digamos
y al acuerdo de ir implementando esta
medida de manera progresiva en el tiempo
el plazo máximo es un plazo de cinco
años donde el primer año va a tener una
obligatoriedad de bajar a cuarenta y
cuatro en dos años posteriores a
cuarenta y dos y finalmente El quinto
año a cuarenta sin embargo estos plazos
son plazos máximos yo creo que eso es
bien importante dejarlo muy en claro son
plazos máximos que cualquier que quiera
anticiparse lo puede hacer tanto en la
gradualidad como también en el resultado
final de hecho te quiero contar que ya
son más de quinientas las empresas que
en nuestro país se han adscrito a la
rebaja de la jornada laboral por la vía
una política pública que implementó el
el gobierno a través del Ministerio del
trabajo para poder establecer una
reducción de la jornada a cuarenta horas
por la vía de lo que llamamos el sello
cuarenta horas y en la gran mayoría de
esta de esta empresa digamos son
pequeñas medianas y microempresas que no
solo la han cambiado la vida a los
trabajadores y trabajadores sino que en
testimonio de ellas mismas han planteado
que esta medida les ha permitido mejorar
su productividad les ha permitido
mejorar como empresa la relación entre
el empleador y el trabajador y los
trabajadores y trabajadoras por lo tanto
es una medida que por la vida de los
hechos ha demostrado que es posible y
que el país no se viene abajo y bueno
Esto de la gradualidad de alguna manera
así un elemento como bien lo decías tú y
lo identificaba parte del acuerdo parte
de la negociación para poder
viabilizarlo para poder tener los votos
en el Congreso Nacional pero que además
lo vuelvo a repetir es un plazo máximo
no mínimo no es decir es decir no parte
de ahí la implementación la
implementación parte ahora ya todos
quienes quieran y estén disponibles
adelantarse lo pueden hacer y van a
tener el apoyo del Estado para eso y por
supuesto los plazos obligatorios son los
que se fijan en este marco de
gradualidad Tal como te lo mencionaba
recién si yo estos días he podido leer
algunas declaraciones suyas además de
otros miembros de su partido del partido
comunista que ponen el foco en una de
las demandas históricas del movimiento
obrero hablan de que esta ley pone a los
trabajadores en el centro del debate que
no se trata de vivir para trabajar sino
de trabajar para vivir bien qué supone
entonces para un trabajador 8 horas
libres semanales en términos de vida
bueno evidentemente Esto es una una
necesidad que los trabajadores y
trabajadoras nos plantean
permanentemente para poder mejorar sus
tiempos libres para poder tener más
tiempo con la familia para poder hacer
deporte para poder finalmente llegar un
poco más temprano a su casa disponer de
mejor manera de sus tiempos o sea ocho
horas de trabajo ocho horas de descanso
cierto son precisamente algunos de los
elementos que se venían planteando
históricamente cuando parte el debate de
la reducción de la jornada laboral
Precisamente en la búsqueda de mejorar
la calidad de vida de las personas tú lo
decías muy bien vivir para trabajar no
es lo deseable las personas se acuestan
para pensando en trabajar al día
siguiente y se levantan para ir a su
trabajo y el tiempo personal la vida
privada el cuidado de los hijos de hija
finalmente Este es un proyecto de ley
que lo que busca es conciliar mucho más
la vida personal la la el poder hacer
cosas distintas el tiempo libre y por
supuesto también el trabajo propiamente
tal Por lo tanto evidentemente es una
medida Pro trabajador y trabajadora los
trabajadores chilenos al menos los
trabajadores organizados en la central
unitaria en la asociación nacional de
empleados Fiscales en la organización de
la coordinadora Nacional de sindicatos
por las cuarenta horas están contentos
con esta medida a pesar de que sin duda
todavía hay cosas que mejorar no fue
todo lo que queríamos porque en un
proceso de negociación siempre hay que
ceder algunas cosas pero este proyecto
por lo menos resguarda la titularidad
sindical le permite a los trabajadores
tener mejores condiciones de vida y por
supuesto avanzar en una política pública
que la oit tiene proponiendo desde el
año treinta y dos diputada le tengo que
cortar nos quedamos ya sin tiempo ha
sido un placer hablar con usted sobre
esta reforma en Chile le agradecemos de
nuevo su tiempo y esperamos quizás poder
hablar con usted en otra ocasión Muchas
gracias
muchas gracias a ustedes también que
estén muy bien a ti ya nuestros
televidentes los esperamos ya en unos
segundos porque sigue directo a América
en France 24
[Música]